a fortified tower on monte titano the
mountain towers 740 meters over the tiny
Republic composed of nine municipalities
called Castelli or castles one of them
is the capital city San Marino high up
on the mountain you can walk from the
northeastern corner of the country to
its southwestern end in about three
hours
San Marino has all of 61 square
kilometers the city gate porta Francesco
leads to San Marino's old city a UNESCO
World Cultural Heritage Site since 2008
the basilica holds the grave of a mini
state's founder Saint marinus a
stonemason he fled here in 8301 to avoid
persecution like many Christians and
Jews after him the country has always
been independent Marino is the world's
oldest Republic so for me it's a very
special country
phasic the country has great potential
and a wonderful history that isn't as
honored as it deserves to be Valerie
SATA Bello it's very beautiful
unique and above all quiet here the
changing of the guard in front of the
government palace the Palazzo publico
San Marino has never had a king the
Parliament elects two captains region
for terms of six months
Teodoro LAN Fani knee is San Marino's
Minister of Tourism he says that
although San Marino is completely
surrounded by Italy it insists on its
independence
no-no-no question even Taji the point
isn't the practical advantages of having
your own estate it's about tradition our
country is the world's oldest Republic
and has always preserved its
independence I think the citizens of San
Marino will hold on to their unique
ancient traditional unit la tradición de
que representa mo the same the three
fortresses of san marino are impossible
to overlook
laQuita is the largest and oldest
a.height takes you to the second tower
machista the architect Leo Moreno more
gonti knows when each layer of the wall
here was built including in the third
tower the Mont ollie
of course the towers were built to
defend the Republic against enemy
attacks this is an outpost of the
district of Montefeltro not far from the
adriatic sea
Adri article
a state celebrates its history crossbow
archery is the national sport of the
summit in a safe here at a Medieval Fair
the arrows plunge into the target from a
distance of 32 metres the various
municipalities compete for the trophy
from best archer for crossbow archery
goes back very far here in San Marino
the oldest document about it is from the
Year 1339 'then all the different
Castelli our Castle municipalities can
be compared not only in terms of sports
but also across a new series of postage
stamps the mini Republic presents itself
in miniature form poins and stamps are
very special many collectors come
especially to Monte Titano to buy them
they're a comprar a very productive they
really are quite special
avianna grandchildren visitors ascend
the heights on a cable car since 1959 it
has connected the town of Borgo Maggiore
with San Marino's old city higher up on
the mountain
after a few minutes passengers reached
the Piazza Navona with its Statue of
Liberty there's also a michelin-rated
restaurant here the ossetia drinking on
the menu are handmade noodles and
regional desserts epical of san marino
is string ghetto
noodles made from a very robust dough
also typical classics are strange
made from old bread and the cream desert
hotel de su propio property Cimmerian
san marino a tiny state that has always
been self-reliant while remaining open
to the world